hi I'm Erik Bosse and Benham just
released a new trailer with some spruced
up CGI from the trailer that was
apparently shown at Comic Con in the
sickest gasoline fights since Zoolander
let's break down this trailer frame by
frame for all the details that you might
have missed and spoiler warning in case
of my predictions into beam right let's
get started
I'm a debride I'm a reporter now I
always seem to find myself questioning
something that government it may not be
working at okay after an opening shot of
San Francisco we see Tom Hardy as
reporter Eddie Brock appearing to
investigate a prison perhaps Brock is
working on a piece about incarceration
or maybe he's digging into experiments
with prisoners being used as test
subjects more on that theory later we
also see more shots of that crash site
that we saw in past trailers but now
check out this yellow van it has Chinese
characters on it establishing this
setting as China
more specifically hong kong which we do
see later in this trailer
then there's Riz Ahmed as Carlton Drake
head of the Life Foundation opening the
back to this van and the camera pulls
back even further than in past trailers
to reveal multiple symbiote samples the
furthest back being a yellow color this
movie's being adapted from the venom
lethal protector comic which features
Eddie Brock venom as kind of an antihero
as opposed to the villain to spider-man
he fights against the light foundation
and five ultimate symbiotes that it
spawns scream agony riot phage and
Lasher and this yellow symbiote is most
likely the one for screen which in the
comics has a bright yellow color with
some red lining and it attaches to the
woman Donna Diego at Comic Con o has
suggested that this movie will establish
more of the symbiotes extraterrestrial
origin see in the comics there an alien
race called the Clint are originally the
symbiote found Eddie Brock by means of
Peter Parker who ran into the parasite
in space and carried it himself for a
bit turn in his suit black but then the
venom character comes after it detaches
from spider-man but since it looks like
spider-man will not be in this movie
this story will have to go further into
the Clint's are back story to explain
its origin because that's the part of
venom everyone loves the Clint are apart
moving on I found something
really bad here any explorers the light
foundation labs running into this female
test subject to me this looks like the
female host that we see later in the
trailer and I'll actually explain who I
think she is when we get there really
the detail I want to talk about here is
the voice of venom Tom Hardy is doubling
up as Venom's voice apparently saying
all of his lines whilst burping I
actually think they've cleaned up
Venom's audio a bit since the last
trailers even though some of you had
trouble making out everything that he
says at times but don't worry we here at
new rock stars have you covered with
some subtitles see here he says just
want some ice cream Eddie moving on look
around the world this section Drake
talks us through his villainous agenda
as we see three world cities Hong Kong
Glasgow and London shortly after it is a
shot of Earth's surface seen from space
so my guess is that the alien symbiotes
that crashed onto the planet will be
scattered across these cities with
Drake's Life Foundation gathering each
of them together his explanation of this
man that human beings are disposable
suggests to me that this guy might be a
convict who volunteered himself for
scientific research
perhaps that's how Eddie Brock's
reporting led him to these experiments
the symbiote in this cell has an orange
tint on this inky surface maybe we're
looking at phage the symbiote with the
orange yellowish color who attaches
himself to the man Carl mock you look
closely at these shots the way the
symbiote invades his bodies pretty
frightening like something out of a
David Cronenberg movie notice how his
neck bulges out and then later as it
swallows up his torso on the floor you
can see it's spilling out of his mouth
yep meanwhile Drake watches all this
with just a creepy fascination actually
look closely behind them you can see
Jenny Slade's character struggling to
avert her gaze I assume this is the
experiment that leads her to be a
whistleblower source for Eddie let me
not
me
[Applause]
okay here we see Eddie in the lab with
the MRI machine with an interesting
flicker effect on his body as the Venom
symbiote freaks out traditionally the
symbiotes weakness is sonic waves so
maybe it's responding to the MRI which
is loud as hell though technically MRIs
operate with radio waves and
electromagnetism not sonic waves but I'm
just looking to fart
the symbiote helps Eddie take out these
guards and escape on his motorcycle oh
my god excellent crossover confirmed
sorry did just this job has kind of made
me paranoid at every exit let's move on
to the next clip we cannot just hurt
people
okay
this trailer continues to be one of the
creepiest ones to pause on with this
quick frame of Eddie's face halfway
through transforming into venom eggs
this reminds me a lot of that terrifying
bilbo baggins jump scare and fellowship
at the ring there's also this
cool-looking shot of venom protruding
from Eddie's arm in talking ohm like a
snake which is an image pulled directly
from the comics muscle get some pretty
nauseating images of Eddie's twisted
shattered legs being in humanely
straightened out healed with the power
of the symbiote the VFX here look very
similar to the limb regrowth during
penny wises transformation at the end of
its last year or maybe Rick Sanchez had
some leftover broken-leg Serum and
before I move on and we see more of that
money shot from the last trailer with
Venom's face devouring Eddie's but here
we see the symbiotes inhuman movement
using its tendrils to lift itself off
the ground with feet let's move on
okay so for anyone confused Venom says
this clear he does not say the idea of
having venom wanting to snack on eyes
lungs and pancreas --is is actually a
big part of his character in the comics
this creature is a cannibal he eats
people
yes it's gross and it's a lot for Eddie
Brock to live with yeah it's a now for
me Venom's long tongue leaving a trail
of slobber on this guy's cheek comes off
as eating grosser on to the next clip
that power it's not
cooperate
and you just might survive ok this
section shows off some of the positive
sides of Eddie's venom parasite he uses
a symbiote to form a bulletproof shield
to protect these people from gunfire and
that box says pizzeria Delfina which is
actually a real-life pizza restaurant in
San Francisco and check out this shot of
venom on the catwalk behind it appears
to be some kind of space shuttle
pre-launch so this is interesting
earlier in the trailer Eddie asks venom
what he wants with them and venom says
you'll see so it's still a question what
exactly Venom's gold in this movie will
be assuming it's more than just taking
on the human host and causing chaos
based on this shuttle perhaps the light
foundation plans to send a space shuttle
to the Clinch our homeworld which is in
the Andromeda galaxy in the comics using
navigation coordinates gathered from the
crashed symbiote vessels perhaps the
Venom symbiote smishing is to stop these
evil Earthlings from bridging the two
civilizations that did have pretty
violent results with their mix together
moving on we also see that shot of Eddie
convulsing in the MRI from the first
teaser but now if you pause at the right
frame you can see that flicker effect
projecting venom space from hearties
next there's a shot of an EMT driver
being attacked by another symbiote
causing the ambulance to flip and
following that is a shot of a female
symbiote host:that symbiote more sore
arm into a blade this looks like a very
clear nod to that shape-shifting t1000
and t2 which also took a female form and
had a similar blade arm and if we
ascertain that that yellow symbiote that
we saw earlier with scream my guess is
that this one here could be agony the
other female host Leslie Kazan area in
the comics who is a light foundation
security officer so I think this woman
is the one that Eddie runs into in the
lab earlier in the trailer now agony is
more of a purple color in the comics but
again all of the symbiotes in this
trailer appear to have a more black inky
palette with just faint streaks of a
color on top of it so you kind of feel
colorblind watching all this let's move
on guys you do not want to do this trust
me
we'll always come at a cost
okay this section is framed with the
epic words the world has enough
superheroes which I think it's pretty
solid slogan for this movie the world
does have enough superheroes and for
some reason they all live within a
couple square miles of each other in
Manhattan what happens when bad things
happen to people in Cleveland I guess by
definition of living in Cleveland that's
every day for them man in the lab coat
that Eddie no look chokes is read Scott
from beep it's still unknown though what
character he's playing we also get a
very clear shot of Venom's torso and
chest in this trailer now traditionally
venom has the emblem of a white spider
on his chest which he has because
remember the symbiote was previously
attached to spider-man so he adopts a
lot of his qualities and powers but the
venom in this movie does not have that
in one because again spider-man will not
be a part of this story this venom just
has these cool white veiny marble
patterns now someone said that that
pattern could evolve throughout the film
as the symbiote changes form repeatedly
maybe connect to the bottom to form a V
personally I think that'd be pretty
stupid but we also see that female
symbiote host again maybe agony spraying
these symbiote Barb's from her back damn
the guy on the left gets jabbed both in
the forehead and in the neck and before
I move on we get this epic shot of
another symbiote with a silver color
with his arms morphed into a scythe
shape wiping out this office by the way
we actually saw the shot without the
Simeone in previous trailers was just
the computers in chairs getting knocked
away by nothing making it kind of weird
that they would include the shot without
the main effect in it anyway this is
riot he's one of the five light
foundations symbiotes who has a similar
color palette to venom just a bit
lighter in the comics right is a
symbiote of Trevor Cole but here riots
host is Carlton Drake himself now to be
clear riot is the only confirmed
symbiote besides venom so far so I may
just be reading all this wrong and the
riot symbiote is just the same one that
we saw attaching to the guy with the
long hair in the female EMT and he just
kind of hops from host to host but I
still think it's more likely that we'll
see all five in this movie with
different hosts meanwhile we still don't
know much about carnage other than the
fact that he is supposed to be in this
movie and there's a good chance Woody
Harrelson will be playing Cletus Kasady
the serial killer who fuses to the
symbiote offspring of venom that becomes
carnage but we have not seen woody in
any trailer footage and the filmmaker
said there is a special sequel moment at
the end of the film so I'm guessing
carnage could just show up as a
post-credits scene or maybe the third
act villain that they just don't want to
spoil for us yet like perhaps the world
has learned it's lesson from putting
doomsday
the trailer for Batman V Superman moving
on
miss clip venom and Wright battle in its
pretty savage the two symbiotes collide
fused together in an inky explosion in
the midst of it Eddy and Carlton smaller
bodies face each other this reminds me a
lot of the final battles and movies like
aliens and Ironman where two giant
forces Duke it out but it's humanized by
focusing on the humans inside those
forces as they try to control the larger
exoskeletal suits and again look closely
at what they're fighting in front of
that looks like that space shuttle that
I saw before
notice how printed on the side are the
words life in red and smaller foundation
so yeah I'm thinking there is something
to this theory of the light foundation
wanting to explore outer space and then
I'm desperate to stop that from
happening and on to the final clip okay
Venom's threat to this guy is pretty
violent and just be clear this is what
he says and that's not to be confused
with this oh that is actually what he
says guess the truth is stranger than
fiction pretty colorful imagery their
venom I don't think I've seen a turd
rolling down a street before thankfully
but it did remind me of one of my
favorite similes in the Shawshank
Redemption
it's a miracle like a fart in the wind
this particular image of Eddie with his
face half exposed is really well done
it's a nod to the recurring image of
venom and spider-man split personalities
throughout the Marvel comics and after
biting this dudes head off Tom Hardy's
comedic delivery is pretty solid at the
end here this little smirk he sneaks in
say what you will about the tone or the
dialogue that we've seen in these
trailers but remember we have one of the
best actors playing one of the coolest
characters in the comics there's still a
lot to look forward to but the question
I want to leave you guys with should
carnage be the villain in this movie or
should they save him for a sequel
comment on below with your thoughts or
tweet me a DA vas and follow new
rockstars on Twitter for updates on our
videos like this video share it around
it's
scrag the new rock stars or breakdowns
of all the trailers that came at a
comic-con
Aquaman Shazam glass Godzilla and the
fantastic beasts in the too many words
thank you for watching and to bar the
pronunciation of this movie SIM bye-bye